well it is no secret the apps we use
track our habits online
they then build a profile used to send
us targeted advertisements you notice
that
all of your feeds on social media nancy
chen shows us how that is changing
if you have an iphone or an apple device
iphone and ipad owners are seeing
something new when they open an app on
their device
it's the new app tracking transparency
prompt
it's a feature that gives you a choice a
choice on how apps use and share your
data
apps can track online behavior including
shopping habits
location age and even medical info
that data is being used to target us
with specific ads
apple's latest software update forces
companies to
ask for permission it's expected most
users won't grant that permission which
could lead to big changes in online
advertising
some are even calling this the
adpocalypse cbs news tech reporter dan
patterson
says app developers and ad companies
stand to lose
billions of dollars because they'll
simply no longer be able to build
businesses around selling targeted ads
facebook is one of the apps fighting
against the apple change
earlier this year the social network
took out ads arguing it will limit how
small businesses reach customers
but tech experts say even with the new
permission privacy setting
apps will still be able to gain some
insight about users
this allows you to still help
advertisers make your
messages relevant without telling them
what you're doing tuesday afternoon at
2pm
allen adamson is co-founder of the
marketing for metaphors
and says advertisers will adapt there'll
be some new technology it will change
things
but it's not going to disable the market
place at all google is reportedly
looking into anti-tracking software for
android devices
possibly giving its users the option one
billion
iphone owners now have nancy chen cbs
news new york interesting i'll